all right let's start today not
hyperbolically but just in a way that
aligns with the facts letting you know
that the polling for the 2022 midterms
in both the House and Senate is looking
a little bit worse for Democrats than it
was uh three weeks ago there was a very
clear although for now not massive shift
away from Democrats towards Republicans
in both the House and Senate and this
just is another reminder that we all
have to vote and we have to take nothing
for granted let's start first with the
House of Representatives Republicans
have been favored to win the house and
they remain favored to win the house but
the the rate of the probability of that
event taking place has increased and if
we look at the 538
forecast of the House of Representatives
one of the things that you see is that
over time the Democratic chances of
controlling the house surged from about
June through late September and then
started to decline now it is not a
massive change but there is this
inflection point in late September early
October wherein Republican odds of
controlling the house taking control of
the house have increased what do we do
about it well we all have to vote that
doesn't change but this is starting to
look like a trend we then look at the
Senate
Democrats have been for a while and
remain favored to control the Senate
after the midterms to retain control but
again if you look at how those odds have
changed you see an even more notable
inflection point again this was right
around I don't know mid-september and
since mid-september Democratic odds have
declined and Republican odds have
increased this doesn't change that the
most likely outcome the most likely
single outcome is that Democrats retain
control of the Senate and Democrats lose
control of the house that's been the
most statistically likely outcome for a
while now but it's looking a little bit
less good in the in the Senate and even
worse than it was in the house so what
is the takeaway later on in the show
we're going to be looking at more
debates from yesterday we're going to be
looking at other polling and specific
races the takeaway is simply
every single state
has to be fought for
and whether it's looking like an easy
Democratic win so for example there's a
key race in Michigan the governor of
Michigan Gretchen Whitmer the incumbent
trying to beat off a challenge from
Tudor Dixon and Whitmer is up by
somewhere between 8 and 11 points it's
looking pretty safe but that does that
does that mean our michigander viewers
stay home I certainly hope not uh then
you have very very tight races like for
example in Arizona the Arizona
gubernatorial where Kerry Lake the
deranged big lie conspiracy theorist
Republican
is about half a point to one point ahead
of Katie Hobbs that's a disaster do we
stay home there no actually Arizona is
one of the main places as I talked about
yesterday where we we have to make sure
everybody's voting and then there are
other races that are looking more in
favor of Republicans so an example would
be tonight there's a debate in this race
Marco Rubio the incumbent Republican
senator of Florida he is facing a
challenge from uh democratic
congresswoman Val demings he's up like
five or so do we give that one up no
whether the Democrat is up the
Republican is up or it's a tight race
you're allowed to vote so take advantage
and make sure that you do vote and we'll
look in more detail uh at some of these
other races a little bit later
Stephen Bannon former Trump propagandist
Stephen Bannon awaiting sentencing
he is now potentially facing six months
in jail and a two hundred thousand
dollar fine CNBC reports the Department
of Justice wants Steve Bannon jailed for
six months for contempt of congress but
ex-trump Aid is asking for probation
this is typical prosecution usually asks
for a stricter punishment than the
person who is about to be sentenced the
key points as reported by CNBC
Federal prosecutors recommended Steve
Bannon get six months in jail for
defying that subpoena from the
Congressional probe of the January 6
Capital Riot remember what is that issue
here is that the January 6 committee
subpoenaed Steve Bannon and he ignored
it that's called contempt of congress
and indeed that is what he will be
ultimately sentenced for the doj also
sought a two hundred thousand dollar
fine for Bannon who was a senior advisor
and former president Donald Trump's
White House the doj recommended the
maximum fine and top sentence under the
federal guidelines range because of
bannon's consistent quote bad faith
strategy of defiance and contempt
bannon's lawyers are asking the federal
court for a sentence of probation now
there are some who are reacting to this
and have emailed me and said David you
know I don't like Steve Bannon as much
as the next person but this is just too
high I mean six months for defying a
subpoena that's Bonkers on the other
hand there are people who wrote it and
say said you know this is actually
really serious if we actually are for
Law and Order
and we respect separation of powers and
we respect the constitutionally assigned
task of the House of Representatives
representatives to conduct
investigations then you have to take
really seriously what Steve Bannon did
because he deliberately
willingly
brazenly I would argue
obstructed the House of Representatives
from carrying out its constitutionally
assigned task and that needs to be taken
really seriously you you can make
arguments on both sides I do believe
that this needs to be taken seriously
and I know that the stricter the penalty
for Stephen Bannon the more he and other
trumpists will make him out to be a
martyr someone who was made an example
out of for no reason other than the Maga
people are being attacked and whatever
else
uh but you've still got to assign the
penalties that are appropriate for the
wrongdoing that was done and it should
be taken seriously so we have the
sentencing uh coming up let me see if I
can find the actual date here in the
article uh he's gonna be sentenced
Friday okay so by the beginning of next
week we will
um know about that however his lawyers
also asked to stay any sentence imposed
pending the outcome of an appeal so once
the sentence happens it's not likely
that if a prison is a jail rather is
assigned that he's going to serve that
anytime soon because they have already
made clear they plan to appeal and will
ask for a stay of that sentence six
months too high too low let me know in
the YouTube comments on Twitter email in
info davidpackman.com
one little story about projection that I
want to tell you about one of the really
popular story lines from the American
right wing for more than a decade now I
remember Rick Santorum talking about
this uh maybe in the bush era certainly
early in the Obama era
is the story that they tell where they
claim the left is indoctrinating our
children they of course more recently
talk about the left is indoctrinating
children in elementary school for a
while they've been arguing and claiming
not very convincingly I might add that
college and university are nothing but
left-wing indoctrination
uh at the same time it is they who are
overtly truly overtly trying to
indoctrinate our children there is a
publication called the kids guide I
don't totally understand whether Mike
Huckabee the former Arkansas Republican
Governor is the publisher of this
nonsense or just a spokesman
but the kids guide as it says and you
can see it on the screen if you're
watching today will help your kids learn
the truth about President Trump
and to celebrate America with a free
patriotic gift bundle and you sign up
for this thing and it's sort of free
except you've got to pay shipping and
handling I guess for each of the items
that they send you and then based on
what some people told me it's only free
for the first month and you've got to
pay 20 bucks a month and on and on and
on this is overt right wing propaganda
oh yeah here it is uh you can get a new
kids guide every three to four weeks for
21.90 each and then you get
the magazine alone for 7.95 and it's all
it's all crazy so it is another one of
these grifts but it is another
indoctrination here is a um a little
clip here uh yes as you can see you just
pay a dollar each for shipping on this
stuff okay here's a little clip from uh
an ad for this very same kids guide hey
parents and grandparents as we wait to
see what's next for president Trump Mike
Huckabee's education company as we
anxiously wait oh and I guess it is
Huckabee's company Huckabee's education
company wants to help your kids learn
all about President Trump's greatest
achievements during his first term
that's why we're giving away the kids
guide to president Trump for free this
fun kids guide will help your kids to
understand everything president Trump
has already accomplished for America
what's more it's part of a very special
gift bundle that includes a free Kids
magazine and a free video Lesson too
yeah this is the indoctrination and you
know I don't know whether I would call
it funny it's actually really sad and
scary the indoctrination that they worry
about from the left especially in
college is being indoctrinated into
critical thinking
media literacy
these are not actually indoctrinations
these are some of the most important
tools critical thinking isn't a belief
system it's a framework and a set of
tools to figure out for yourself what
you should believe and what you should
not believe and
I mean give them some credit the right
seems to accurately realize that when
you give people those tools so that when
they hear abortion is murder supply-side
economics is good there's no such thing
as climate change people can think for
themselves and evaluate and say hey you
know what
uh let's actually go on Google Scholar
and search for peer-reviewed studies on
that thing that they're telling me and
let me figure out for myself what's true
and what isn't when I hear a media
message let me think through what are
the biases of the platform on which I'm
hearing this what are the biases of the
host that is telling me this those are
tools which don't lead to right wing
nuttery in fact they prevent it and so
to the extent that the right wing
recognizes that critical thinking and
media literacy and epistemology will
hurt their movement they are activating
against it but it's not indoctrination
it's not indoctrination and they seem to
know in order to survive as a movement
they need to lie to people and tell them
College will indoctrinate you well
College will teach you to think for
yourself something that is not
particularly revered among this movement
send me your thoughts find me on Twitter
at dpacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
remember that the David Pacman show is
of course an audience viewer listener
supported program primarily through
something we call membership you can
sign up at joinpakman.com not only do
you directly support the work that we do
at very reasonable rates I might add you
also get an extra show every single day
called the bonus show you get the
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show every day as well as
invitations to our members only Town
Hall events the last of which was
it's been about four weeks ago or
something like that we'll be scheduling
the next members only Town Hall very
soon sign up at joinpakman.com all right
let's check in on the Herschel Walker
campaign Herschel Walker is the
Republican Senate candidate in Georgia
Herschel Walker knows very little about
anything he had a debate uh last week
during which he flashed a fake badge he
claims to be a police officer he claims
to have trained with the FBI he has been
credibly accused of paying for an
ex-girlfriend's abortion and urging her
to have a second abortion despite
claiming to be vehemently pro-life
against abortion abortion is murder no
exceptions whatsoever except he has paid
for a woman's abortion We are continuing
to follow the breakdown of any semblance
of truth and reality from Herschel
Walker so let's go through piece by
piece first and foremost he was
interviewed Herschel Walker was
interviewed by NBC News
and in this NBC news interview he
continues to claim no I never paid for
anyone's abortion and the explanation
that he gives in this clip suggests
either he doesn't know how many or which
children he has okay that's possible or
you have to believe in time travel for
this explanation to make sense so let me
set it up for you Herschel Walker's new
denial is okay fine I do know the woman
who says I paid for her to get an
abortion after urging her to get an
abortion
I did send her a 700 check but I sent
her the 700 check for the child we have
together the only problem
is the check was sent years before that
child was born
so is it a case of time travel did
Herschel Walker travel back in time to
give her the money for a kid that would
be born years later I don't know take a
listen this is still alive because she's
the mother of my child so you're going
to see my chick of somebody giving a
check so that I'm saying it's a lot do
you know what this seven hundred dollars
I have no idea what that can be for is
that your signature though let me see it
could be and it doesn't matter whether
it's my signature or not yes that's my
check yep okay so yes it's my my
signature yes I sent 700 to this woman
yes I do know the woman despite
previously playing dumb about it until
you no longer could because she's the
mother of one of your children the money
was because we have a child together but
that child did not exist at the time
that he sat the 700 check now in
Herschel Walker's defense if I
understand the timeline he did have a
different kid with a different woman
that very same year it's possible that
he's confused about which woman he sent
the 700 to I don't know the other
possibility is that Walker is confusing
children that he has I just don't know
and it is quite stunning how many media
Outlets continue to accept these bogus
explanations without doing the just
fundamental math it's it's not even
really math it's just understanding time
and that time moves forward as far as we
understand it right now
and that the timing completely debunks
these completely bogus stories and
unfortunately
almost everybody is kind of treating him
with kid gloves on this even during the
debate last week with Raphael Warnock as
I told you one of the worst moderated
debates I've ever seen the moderators
not pressing at all just oh the story is
untrue all right well he says it's
untrue well but hold on a second
is the woman in question the mother of
one of your children well yeah so you do
know the woman yes and you were dating
her at the time that she claims you paid
for her abortion well yeah I guess I was
and is it possible that she became
pregnant due to someone else's doing
well no they could easily break this
down and get to the bottom of it very
very quickly
but they can continue to teach uh treat
him with kid gloves and it is abundantly
clear at this point that he is lying
speaking of lying Herschel Walker is
doubling down about his bogus police
badge as a reminder Herschel Walker
flashed a bogus police badge during his
debate with Rafael Warnock late last
week Raphael Warnock correctly pointed
out Herschel Walker has falsely claimed
to be a police officer Herschel Walker
took out a badge now a badge in and of
itself doesn't actually mean anything
but Herschel Walker continues to focus
on the badge you have to see this clip
this is also part of the NBC news
interview with Herschel Walker he says
it's a real badge and the badge was
given to me by a police officer and then
listened to what Walker claims the badge
allows him to do this is just beyond
belief let's talk about that moment at
the debate where you flash the badge I
don't know if you have the badge with
you but a lot of people are wondering
what was that badge do you have that is
legit okay it's a legit badge he says
let's continue uh that's a badge that I
was given by a police officer okay a
police officer gave him the badge I do
have the bag you have it I I carry it
with me all the time it's not it's a
real badge it's not a fake bad it is by
the way at what point does this become
impersonating a police officer they real
bad who gave you the badge this badge is
from uh this bad and I have badges all
over the All Over Georgia wait we're not
to believe that he's an officer All Over
Georgia are we people from Chatham
County I have way way I had from Chatham
County which is the county which is the
county
which is encountered from uh you know I
have it upside down make sure it's right
which is accounted from where Senator
one night is from I have an honorary
sheriff badge from that County oh it's
honorary well that is meaningless
Herschel where's this one from this is
from my hometown this is from Johnson
County from the sheriff from Johnson
County which is a legit badge everyone
can make fun but this bad give me the
right and wait let me finish if anything
happened in this counter I have the
right to work with the police and
getting things done okay did you hear
what he just said
he's using he's using words
he's
the his vocal cords are vibrating and
producing sound
audible to the human ear
but it doesn't mean anything he says the
bet the honorary badge gives him the
right it's interesting for him to use
the word the right when these right
Wingers insist we actually have very few
rights but now he says an honorary badge
gives him the right you have the right
to to do what to work with police work
with them in what way if anything
anything like what happens in this
County
it doesn't mean anything how far does
this charade have to go before Herschel
Walker can be charged with impersonating
a police officer and understand that
since the Fiasco at the debate last week
they obviously brought in the entire
staff presumably to figure out how do we
deal with this and what they came up
with was
keep carrying the badge
keep flashing the badge and insist that
you're like sort of a police officer
it's absolute and utter insanity and
this isn't even the most humiliating
badge related event over the last 24
hours all right
let's do one more Herschel Walker badge
related story
this may be the funniest video I've seen
this entire campaign cycle in order to
continue defending
his having a badge which is completely
meaningless
completely honorary
confers absolutely no law enforcement
powers or abilities to Herschel Walker
of any kind whatsoever
he got a police officer I guess and you
know I have to say
he got an obese police officer to say I
gave Herschel this badge because he's my
friend and I tweeted about this and
there were people online who were saying
David why is it relevant that the guy is
obese you're fat shaming not at all
part of the absurdity of this entire
thing is is this guy even really a
police officer and part of it is
in general police officers at least
shouldn't be allowed to be morbidly
obese okay it's not about fat shaming
it's about listen we understand you
can't have
a 55 year old morbidly or obese
firefighter it doesn't work or military
personnel or emergency medical
technicians or whatever
but do do we actually have 55 year old
morbidly obese police officers and if so
why is that guy the one who is the one
saying I gave Walker this badge and it
also makes it less believable this guy's
even really a police officer now again I
the guy doesn't have the the sort of
like police belt he doesn't have a
firearm he's just wearing like a hat and
a shirt I don't even know if this guy's
really a police officer so that's the
relevance of the Obesity okay it's not
about fat shaming here's Herschel Walker
and his friend says he gave him the
badge this is Herschel Walker this is
the badge I flash at the debate and this
is my Share Sheriff Roland yes if
herschel's badge is a prop then I guess
this badge I'll wear every day to
protect the citizen I guess it's a prop
also
but these are real badges and I gave
this to my friend for all he's done for
this country in this Camp okay so I may
maybe in this part of Georgia the
sheriff
dresses like this I I don't know I gave
this to my friend isn't exactly Herschel
Walker is in law enforcement every
single one of these moments that are
meant to prove that Herschel Walker is
really sort of a police officer
only reinforce the reality that he is
not and these are the sorts of moments
where you know I have family in
different parts of the world Europe
Argentina Etc
and I hear from them and they say what
the hell is going on what what is going
on with this Herschel Walker guy I
wouldn't want either of these guys
protecting me or my family
it every single step the story gets even
more insane and now the latest is
herschel's my friend and I gave him a
badge well I guess he's a police officer
then right it's pathetic folks all these
clips you can find on our Instagram at
davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today we
welcome to the program Melissa Peltier
who's an award-winning filmmaker and
producer of the documentary the game is
up disillusioned Trump voters tell their
stories Melissa really great having you
on I appreciate your time
thank you I'm excited to be here so you
know we we've seen and even done
interviews at Trump rallies with those
who are not disillusioned in other words
they still are Trump supporters and and
it's interesting to ask them why they
have not abandoned Donald Trump given
that of course just about every promise
he made he didn't keep he made very
clear that he only even really cares
about these folks to the extent that
they're useful to him and then he no
longer cares you know all these things
so we've heard from the people that are
that are sticking with them you did
something interesting which is you spoke
to many disillusioned Trump voters to
figure out why are they no longer uh
sort of part of the cult as as it may be
was there one coherent story about what
ultimately drove them away or was it
really different things for different
people
it was different
um there were a couple people who had
pinpointed
um Helsinki uh with Trump and Putin as
one trigger but I mean everyone kind of
mentioned that I think all along but
everybody had a different reason because
they all had different reasons for
voting for him
oh that's interesting so in other words
the reasons whatever originally
attracted them to Trump was a factor in
what ultimately dissuaded them exactly
can you give a couple examples
well uh off the top of my head our
farmer
um Chris Gibbs he was you know he was
kind of laser focused on the
agricultural aspect of it which is you
know you have to remember that people
often vote just for their own personal
reasons not just because their blanket
they're a racist or they're whatever uh
he was really laser focused on
agriculture he liked the idea that Trump
was going to lift the Waters of the U.S
rule uh he he was just he didn't like
Trump
you know like he wasn't in love with him
but he voted for him because he didn't
like Hillary and he also felt that Trump
was really kind of anti-anti uh
government on your property kind of
thing and so he voted for him and he was
impressed with some of the things he did
in the beginning and then he began to
see what Trump's real agricultural
policy was doing and really the trade
Wars just decimated the agriculture
business and nobody knows that
except the people who were decimated
only a few of them I think with Trump
with uh like like Chris have gone away
from Trump but he was watching it very
carefully he had actually worked for the
Department of Agriculture as a a
Farmville guy and he just was disgusted
with it and then he kept hearing Trump
lie and lie and lie like saying the
China China's paying the tariffs and he
just broke it was it that was it the
tariffs thing is interesting because
it doesn't really seem that Donald Trump
has ever understood how how tariffs work
and of course he insists China pays the
tariffs but really what happens is the
United States puts a tariff on Chinese
Imports and so whoever is buying the
Chinese Imports still pays China for the
stuff but then also pays a tariff to the
United States government now there's
like macroeconomic stuff which would
indicate that over time China would
lower the prices in order to account for
the Tariff okay but that that's not but
the nuts and bolts of how the Tariff
works in your experience did did Chris
understand that all along or did he come
to know it after those terrorists were
put in place or how did he understand
that
well he he first of all he was very
angry about also withdrawing from TPP
okay but with the tariffs I think I mean
he was smart enough to know what would
happen yep and I think he didn't know
how long it might go on but when it
really really dragged on and really
started killing their business uh
because as he points out you know it was
actually farmers who negotiated those
those International agreements Farmers
had you know their buyers and they had
and they've been doing this over 30
years and basically overnight Trump
wiped away their their tried in two
markets you um speak in the film to a
Jewish woman who was a trump supporter
and then Charlottesville happened and
Trump made the fine people on both sides
comments which I am glad to admit were
slightly taken out of context and were a
little bit different than what was the
original reporting but needless to say
it still impacted this this particular
woman
um can you talk about that a little bit
and I mean this is kind of a bigger
Trend wherein
actual American Jews are one of the most
left-wing voting blocs that there is
recently Trump has done this thing on
Truth social where he says you know the
American Jews should really shape up
here because bad things could happen you
should be more appreciative talk about
the Jewish woman you spoke to and how
her views changed I I haven't talked to
her in a little bit she's in college in
Israel but um I think that uh she was a
Brooklyn girl and she was the head of
the Brooklyn uh young Republicans in
fact she'd revived the club
um and she was extremely Republican she
was really dedicated she was very young
when she got into it but she was blowing
people away with how what she could do
and how what she knew and she hung out
with those Turning Point people and you
know all the young the young Charlie
Kirk type
Republicans and she was a really really
a true believer in Trump absolutely she
worked you know to help get him elected
she worked on Republican campaigns in
New York and
she went to rallies I mean she talks
about the rallies as being like a a very
unhealthy drug
where everybody sort of got even more in
his thrall the more the longer the rally
the longer they waited in line in fact
and so she really was all in for him and
then she heard the Charlottesville
comment and it really upset her and
disappointed her because of family who
had been killed in a holocaust and she
was very aware of it and she also was
very upset by Charlottesville and her
parents actually were refusenix who was
escaped from Russia
right around the time of uh perestroika
so they had finally got out she her the
her mom's
dad had been a dissident so her mom was
on the watch list just because of her
dad and so it took them a long time to
get out and they had told her her whole
life she was born in the U.S
they told her her whole life that you
know this is this is what happens when
you get this kind of extremism this is
what happens this is what happens and
she started to see that happening and
then shortly after that she saw a
Helsinki and Putin and she started to
get scared and she started to realize
this guy is dangerous he's not what I
thought he was and I think you know the
very fine people on both sides comment
she was interviewed by a local news
station and said what what did the
Brooklyn young Republicans think of that
and she said well we were all very
disappointed and she immediately gets a
call from the head of the New York
Republican party saying why did you say
that and she said I just said we were
disappointed it's just how we felt and
he said well you can't say that we're
Republicans can't say anything bad about
Trump and that really that was another
trigger for her with her parents because
uh you know they told her how you were
what you said was controlled and what
your thought was controlled and she just
really that really got to her so it took
her a little bit of time but she finally
realized she didn't care she didn't want
this guy
the uh you mentioned the rallies and
I've covered so many of these Trump
rallies and and it is absolutely true
that the lines to get in even when there
aren't that many people the lines to get
in are still crazy because of multiple
layers of security sometimes they're
held in really rural places that aren't
actually equipped to handle the number
of people that are going all sorts of
different reasons Trump often runs you
know an hour or more late and folks are
sometimes there all day sanicans blazing
sun you know all the horrible conditions
in my mind it's who would go through
this in order to hear this guy give the
exact same speech that he gives
everywhere the feedback you got is the
long wait almost reinforced The Cult
oh yeah um there's a psychology to Long
Waits and um it's one of the reasons
sometimes artists on purpose will go out
late it it basically it makes you
believe that you know you've already
thrown in you've driven all the way
there you've gotten in line you've
gotten your tickets now you're waiting
wow this must be really important
because I'm waiting so long and it
starts to that the value in your
psychology of this event goes up
so it primes you to think wow we finally
got in this is it you know it's like
getting into a Rolling Stones concert
right and Joe Walsh's wife Helene said
it was like a big rock you know rock
music event
one of the interesting things is that
once the rally actually starts we've
seen so many times
when Trump starts rambling the crowd
will look visibly bored sometimes they
start filing out even during the speech
it's almost like it's just about Trump's
there and he starts speaking and then it
becomes almost irrelevant what he says
they've been there for the event
right right I think that's a big part of
it and all so I remember reading an
article I think it was in the post about
how tailgate parties and the people that
you see at rallies become your friends
even though they live a state away and
so that there was a whole event part of
it like a reunion of all these
like-minded people who thought Trump was
like the Messiah and that was a big part
of it too
um and one of the things again Helene
pointed out is that there's the same
group of people who go from rally to
Rally to Rally to Rally yes yeah you
bring in locals or whatever but but he
has a core group who come in buses and
they go to all the rallies it's like
they go to Every Grateful Dead concert
the same thing so Evangelical support
for Trump this is something that in 2016
we saw you know because there was a very
big Republican primary of which Trump
only had a very small slice to begin
with and as we all know now from the
historical record slowly but surely
different people were sort of fell off
and the the support Consolidated around
Trump the Evangelical vote was initially
very much not around Trump in the
Republican primary and when we think
about about why it seems sort of obvious
Trump is a guy who was in favor of
choice for 68 years and then had to come
up with this story of why he became
against abortion not a church-going guy
married divorced cheating all these
different things so it sort of made
sense that he didn't have the
Evangelical support eventually he got
most of the Evangelical support and the
way we look at it now is well they
weren't going to vote for Hillary and
it's sort of like that simple what more
is there to the eventual Evangelical
support for Trump
well how I understand it is that he
promised them he would he would make
sure you know to appoint these
anti-abortion judges right leaders of
the community but the people we talk to
really they were influenced by their
pastors a couple in um Detroit had had
pastors uh who would tell them
you know from the pulpit who to vote for
and who was evil Hillary you know evil
and then there was another uh
Evangelical that we put we profiled who
is um he he's just recently Liberty
University graduate that was going to be
his first election and he said basically
at Liberty University they did all but
tell you
where to make your mark I mean they
basically
everything was pro-trump they had a
rally for him there it was uh Flyers
everywhere it was it was the whole
Community being told in essence to do
this and Evangelical Christians tend to
be very uh sort of hierarchical in terms
of
um we listened to our pastors they're
above us
and so pastors have a huge amount of
power and if they're preaching from the
pulpit to the vote for
or go to hell or or you know or the
woman who comes in is going to you know
prevent you from ever going to church
again which is one of the things they
said that you know she was going to
destroy the churches
um which is of course totally not backed
up by anything she was actually a pretty
religious person but I think you know
people hear it from their Pastor they
want to hear a simple thing yes no good
bad and that's what they heard and so
that's how they voted and they still
believe that so you told us about the
farmer who over
agricultural policy bailed on Trump you
told us about the Jewish woman who Over
Charlottesville bailed on Trump what
what are some of the other reasons
people gave for you know how did they
feel betrayed by Trump I guess
well Joe Walsh it was definitely
Helsinki and Putin but it I actually got
inspired to make this documentary by
watching Joe Walsh in in real time
change over Twitter yeah because it was
fascinating to watch him completely turn
around over about a year and a half and
uh for him it was Helsinki and that was
like his I mean as he described he was
throwing things around the room and he
was because he really felt that was
treason that was his belief but uh the
evangelicals had different reasons
um one of them was
um uh the Liberty University grad he had
lived all over the world with his
parents who were teachers
internationally they had taught in South
Korea they taught in Saudi Arabia so he
had a much more Global Perspective and
he really felt that what Trump was doing
to the refugees Beyond just what he was
doing to them it was more the way he
talked about them and the more way he
made them sound like a plague and that
really helped sent him because having
lived all over the world he's seen all
sorts of conditions and he believed that
his Christianity you know made him need
to love all those people and welcome
them and try to help them it's rather
the demonizing so that was what really
turned him around
um the other couple uh the the husband
was a machinist and he had only been a
Christian for about four years and he
went to his pastor and said you know I'm
not sure I like this guy Trump I know I
don't feel very good about him and the
Pastor said yeah but you know we need to
get we need to get the judges in and we
get some laws passed and this is the
best thing for Christianity and he just
said okay well that's what I'll do then
and he describes leaving the voting
booth just feeling dirty just feeling
wrong something was wrong he didn't know
what but he pushed it to the back of his
mind until a year or two later he's
sitting in the break room with one of
his workers and the worker he's talking
about Christianity and God to this
worker and the worker is like I just
don't see why I would want to be a
Christian if you support such a terrible
human being
and it was like a lightning bolt hit it
wow and you heard it and that you know
when people change when people leave
Colts whatever you never know what it is
it's going to be the first crack in that
in that bubble yeah but once that crack
happens if enough more information gets
through gradually that can change
people's mind and for him for uh um Ron
this guy uh this Evangelical who was in
our dock he went home and he started
looking in the scripture for himself at
this point he's been a Christian long
enough and he really knows how to study
it he goes to Bible study three times a
week and he finds all sorts of passages
that describe people like Trump being
bad right and he said nope nope nope I'm
done I'm done with this guy the film is
the game is up Dizzle disillusioned
Trump voters tell their stories we've
been speaking with the filmmaker Melissa
Peltier super interesting work and I
really appreciate your time today
oh thank you for having me thanks
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
let's talk about the much anticipated
debate last night between the current
Republican Georgia Governor Brian Kemp
and the Democratic Challenger Stacy
Abrams Stacy Abrams is genuinely
brilliant she's really good at debates
she actually knows things about so many
different issues and it came through in
the debate but Brian Kemp just couldn't
resist doing the angry black woman
routine
check out what he had to say this is
really like a good old boy tired debate
strategy the black woman is upset and
she's mad and she's angry I know Miss
Abrams is upset and mad
and that knowing tilt of the head from
Stacy Abrams now I have to tell you
she was no more mad than anybody else on
the stage in fact the libertarian guy uh
was Furious that they wouldn't take his
idea seriously because they're crazy
ideas
um or let him speak as much as much as
he wanted to and we're going to get to
that in a moment but this entire you're
mad and upset she was no more mad and
upset than anybody else and it was just
another one of these pathetic racially
based tropes now she did really really
well
um at one point when uh she was asked
something along the rights along the
lines of what's the biggest danger
facing Georgia she said the biggest
danger is the guy who's currently the
governor this is a governor who's for
the last four years has beat his chest
but delivered very little for most
Georgians he has weakened gun laws and
flooded our streets he has weakened our
privacy rights and our and women's
rights he has denied women the access to
reproductive care the most dangerous
thing facing Georgia is four more years
of Brian Kemp we need a governor who
actually understands the math and the
morality yeah this is a governor she um
I mean listen it's very common right now
that candidates don't know anything like
when you ask Mehmet Oz hey can you um
like talk about health care policy and
how you would bridge the gap between a
and b and what do you think is the best
way to get care but to keep you you know
he'll just go with one of those weird
rants like the one he did about you know
send people to like a medical tent and
just give him like a five minute exam or
something like he doesn't really
understand things at a policy level
there's a total lack of empathy there's
a total lack of pragmatism as to how you
actually get bills passed and and get
money for the things you need to do
Stacey Abrams knows so much like she is
Head and Shoulders above so many of the
people that are running right now and
she's stuck in this insane situation
with a lot of cuckoo Georgia voters many
totally sensible Georgia voters as well
and a governor who goes oh she's angry
she's mad and she's angry and she really
knows about so many different things
here's another clip where Brian Kemp oh
by the way this is another theme in a
lot of the debates that we've been
covering and we've covered now must be
about 10 or so just in the in the last
few weeks the Republican will just lie
about what the law is or lie about their
record they'll just completely make it
up Brian Kemp did a lot of that last
night where he said listen we have a
full background check law for firearms
purchases in Georgia every single
purchase requires a background check and
of course that's not true there's the
private sale loophole there's the Gun
Show loophole and Stacy Abrams can do
nothing to prevent herself from
interrupting understandably so because
Kemp just can't stop lying or won't on
well there there's a background check
there's a federal background check on
every individual that buys a firearm in
the United States of America shouldn't
exist either
that's not true I understand the point
you're making but the point is when you
buy a firearm you get a background check
none of the laws Mr Kemp if you
purchased a weapon in Georgia through a
gun sale or a private sale
she's completely correct of course but
this this is the widely known Gun Show
loophole private sale you know family
family sale loophole and the libertarian
guy in the middle who is trying to talk
over everybody
he says we shouldn't have any background
checks whatsoever I guess I mean he by
the way the libertarian during
yesterday's debate said uh get rid of
um gun safety regulations uh get rid of
Fiat money get rid of public education
give I can't even remember the full list
of what he said then he was Furious no
one was taking him seriously so uh Kelly
Abram Stacy Abrams doing everything she
could here to try to inject some truth
and reality into the conversation uh one
other moment that I will play for you
um a moment about a plans where uh Brian
Kemp took this sort of this is kind of
like a an escape hatch to any issue you
don't really want to deal with is to say
let's study that issue Stacy Abrams was
having none of it when it came to
helping minority-owned businesses a lot
of Georgians including African Americans
and other minorities cannot go to work
if their kids are not in the classroom
we have the lowest unemployment rate in
the country for African-American we also
were named uh the top we're in the top
ten of the states for black
entrepreneurship uh in the state of
Georgia so our economy is incredible and
we will continue to work with all of
those entrepreneurs in the days ahead
and working class Georgians because we
are the ones that have been fighting for
you when Miss Abrams was not we were
giving tax refunds we were doing tax
cuts we were suspending the gas tax to
help you deal with 40-year high
inflation when she was criticizing us
Stacey Abrams 32nd rebuttal I would
point out that Mr Kemp did not address
the needs of purchasing and contracts
for black and brown owned businesses
which is what he's refused to do for the
last 16 years we know that 10.9 billion
dollars has been delivered to the state
of Georgia through two recent acts at
the Congressional level and Brian Kemp
does not have a plan for making certain
that people of color have access to
those contracts access to purchasing it
was only in July of this year that he
finally acknowledged that there might be
a problem he has said that when need to
study it I would tell him just cheat off
of my paper I know the answer we need a
governor who actually believes in equity
racial Equity economic equity in the
state of Georgia and I will deliver so
listen here's the bottom line with this
race unfortunately uh uh Stacy Abrams I
keep mistaking Kemp and saying Kelly
Abrams which is not what I mean to say
Stacy Abrams is falling further and
further behind uh Brian Kemp and much of
this is happening
I believe because there have actually
not been really clear statements made
about what is at stake if these
Republicans win in November now Stacey
Abrams has made it clear
but the bigger picture we have to zoom
out and really think about all of these
races and the supplies in Pennsylvania
the supplies in Florida Arizona Georgia
really everywhere you know we can have
substantive policy debates about what
should the level of Taxation be or as
far as States go property taxes or some
of these other policy things there is a
movement
Nationwide right now from the Republican
Party
wherein their focus is how can we just
take more and more control of all of the
basic systems on which we depend voting
infrastructure education
Torpedoes some of them deliberately in
order to reinforce our control it's
insanely authoritarian and that big
picture I don't think is being
effectively enough communicated to
voters now okay that that's sort of a
bigger rant in terms of the numbers uh
Stacy Abrams five and a half points
behind Brian Kemp on average right now
it's it's not Out Of Reach necessarily
but let's be honest that two and a half
weeks to make up five and a half points
in a gubernatorial race in a sort of
reddish leading state which sometimes
votes for a Democratic president and
right now has two Democratic senators I
should mention
um is a is something that has to be
overcome now one last thought on last
night's debate
there was this libertarian guy who was
also part of the debate and
on the one hand I I've mixed feelings
about as to what position I should take
on this because on the one hand I want
third parties I hate the two-party
duopoly we need more voices at debates
if you qualify for the debate you should
be there and get as much time to speak
as everybody else at the same time
we know the guy has no shot he was a
complete lunatic anti-vaxx
anti-everything
and he's not going to be the next
Governor so there was also time wasted
from really forcing Brian Kemp to have
to engage with Stacey Abrams on the
issues
and so I I have sort of mixed feelings
about the participation of the
libertarian guy but needless to say
Stacey Abrams super smart did an
incredibly good job will it make a
difference we'll have to wait and see we
now have learned about yet another fraud
perpetrated on you the American taxpayer
by Donald Trump and his family The
Washington Post is now reporting Donald
Trump charged the Secret Service
exorbitant rates at his hotels this was
another grift in order to make money
listen to this records show that in 40
cases the Trump organization billed the
Secret Service far higher amounts than
the approved Government rate in one case
charging agents
1185 dollars a night to stay at the
Trump International Hotel in DC
the new billing documents according to a
congressional committee's review show
that taxpayers paid the president's
company at least 1.4 million dollars for
secret service agent stays at Trump
properties for his and his family's
protection
the records by the way contradict the
repeated claim made by Eric Trump the
president's son and the Trump or
Executive Vice President that the
families company often gave the Secret
Service agents the hotel rooms at cost
or free maybe it was sometimes true but
it often was not this is the latest
grift on you the American people this is
by the way sometimes this is used as a
way to money to launder money which is
like the real price of something is 400
bucks but you start billing 1200 bucks
and then you can launder 800 that that's
not apparently what's going on here here
it's just a form of fraud listen the
hotel room's worth 400 bucks we're going
to charge the government
1200 bucks a night we will direct Secret
Service to stay at these rooms
and then taxpayers are going to pay for
it and it is another complete and total
grift and of course oh Trump donated his
paycheck okay four hundred thousand
dollars a year look at the millions upon
millions of dollars if you look at all
the hotels that were made on the back of
trump being president remember the other
side of this was foreign leaders staying
at Trump properties when they went to DC
or elsewhere to ingratiate themselves
with Donald Trump so it has been a scam
after scam after scam extremely
profitable despite Trump's claim oh I
could have made a bunch more money Trump
made plenty of money while he was
president and so the fact that he
donated his four hundred thousand dollar
salary really is neither here nor there
add it on to the list of more
investigations that will be done we have
a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P here's a caller who's glad
we were banned from tick tock
I'm good I'm glad you were banned from
from tick tock
is your your low life oh well that's
really sad I think the caller will be
saddened to hear
that we are back on Tick Tock so last
week I talked about being banned from
Tick Tock which is increasingly a great
platform for us to be reaching young
people young voters
here's how it all went down over the
weekend
we were originally banned from Tick Tock
for covet and election disinformation
okay we appealed it we were then told no
you're going to continue being banned
for violating the nudity policy now I
can assure you
we did not post any nudity I didn't post
nude pictures of myself there were no
nude pictures of trump posted there was
no nudity on our account whatsoever we
again appealed that and hundreds of you
rode into Tick Tock legal which I very
much appreciate without explanation
the account was reinstated we don't know
why days later
Tick Tock responded and said we've
reversed the decision
your account has been reinstated we
still know very little about what
happened but much to this caller's
dismay we are back on Tick Tock we have
a great bonus show for you today Kanye
West is apparently in talks to buy the
social media platform parlor I know you
probably forgot about parlor we will
talk about it a court has rejected an
appeal to give Americans Samoans U.S
citizenship we will talk about the basis
for that decision and lastly more and
more American companies are charging
employees for job training if they quit
before a certain amount of time has gone
by is it legal yeah it appears to be as
long as it's done in a certain way
is it ethical well that's a different
question all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com